and now the elimination game now in the
world that the left's created a mere
allegation can lead to cancellation Now
by cancellation I mean the loss of
income the loss of a platform the loss
of future opportunities
now of course the strictest enforcement
of this is always against Those whom the
left believes to be hostile to the
liberal worldview
case in point actor comedian and
cultural provocateur Russell Brand the
times of London reported that between
2006 and 2013 several women have accused
him of sexual assault and rape now brand
insists the allegations are false
as I've written about extensively in my
books I was very very promiscuous now
during that time of promiscuity the
relationships I had were absolutely
always consensual
of course none of us knows what the
truth is here I've never met brand and I
only know he's rattled the cage of some
leftist lately for comments he's made I
think about free speech and big Pharma
but we should all understand this it is
dangerous territory we're entering
when accusations published by media
outlets and unaccompanied by a legal
determination of guilt are all that it
takes to destroy someone's livelihood
which is what they're trying to do here
after the allegation surface brand was
immediately demonetized on YouTube while
they continue to keep his videos up so
they can I guess make money and then
they dropped he was dropped by his
talent agency dropped by his book
publisher and a lot of others so just
canceled immediately no further
questions asked
in 2019 they tried to do the same to
that Covington Catholic kid Nick Sandman
he was attacked and painted as racist
because of a few seconds of a viral
video the kid Nick Sandman he did make a
choice and that was to make it into a
standoff these kids are around the guy
and they're all jeering and they're
dancing he's got the smug look on his
face and that's not life everyone that
sees that smug look wants to punch that
kid
whoops Sandman of course uh won a big
out of court settlement against media
outlets on defamation grounds and a year
earlier a police officer was accused of
sexually assaulting a woman he arrested
for DUI then threatening to shoot her
fiancee but body cam footage revealed
the accuser made the entire thing up
and at Yale University the campus was
rocked when a student was charged with
rape there
another female student said that this
individual attacked her in her dorm room
on Halloween night in 2015. the accused
scifcon said that the encounter was
consensual and he was eventually
acquitted in court
that didn't matter Yale still kicked him
out expelled him an allegation was all
it took
he's in the middle of litigation now
against the university and there's more
to come
that former student Saif Khan joins me
now so I've we'll talk about your next
lawsuit in a moment but first tell me
how this
ended up impacting your life good
evening Laura it has eviscerated my life
in every way possible from the harms
that they have presented to my family
and the dangers there was a petition
against me where people were saying all
sorts of nasty stuff and the viciousness
my reputation my my career every single
thing I was able to do in life has been
crippled now because of this allegation
that is baseless I mean people watching
across the country hear that you were
accused of something you said it was a
concerned consensual it was eventually
you eventually acquitted of this
why did the University decide to kick
you out anyway they are a corporation
they are not the government they are not
beholden to Due Process they are not
they don't have to care they have to
Simply see what is their bottom line and
so there was a ton of Campus pressure
from girls feeling uncomfortably being
in class with me or in the dining hall
and so they just expelled me anyway one
of the craziest arguments that Yale had
said was that just because a court of
law says that you're not guilty doesn't
mean we think you're not guilty
well I think again an allegation
that ultimately is not is not proven in
a court of law can still do enormous
damage so if you have another lawsuit
you're filing
I have multiple suits
my main one is against Yale several
administrators including the president
and the Dean and Jane Doe
hmm well safe this is wild we're going
to be following it
um and I certainly think that this this
can't continue what's happening it's
everyone's going to be afraid to say
anything to anyone about anything so
thank you so much up next we're going to
take the Pulse of the nation with Ben
diminish Matt Towery a lot going on so
stay there hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else